babyliss
at home running around here running like it's already
saturday belov coming in here please
son we're not going out yet the day it's too early
to go out
already I want to go there
watch me that
[music]
always travel in people have to the
homes son old ukrainian since the time the
bus in we have dak andrzej this  is if a
siren boston ukraine farmland sporol
fields dolores pounds anger of the us
and sean michaels
a million you came through the
door for all these days of guilt and today 150
thousand people in bov frequent
outbursts where people boast and bombard
van came loans and a draft  inspiring
my family and d are recorded at the temple and
we want in 1 hour I come here and out of
it offline
[music]
and
conditions to live in from under the head
school of course but ok for a few days under
over and time of weeks form and where is your
throw out the idea of ​​​​country house and
bad but barry forges superior sees the
mounts the army container I carry and although
contact with the
executioner will define me with will define centendre grid
tu
using the
man with container sura u  little
tove fanta and the statuses of the processes
chlorpromazine disks and campus with
[music]
I’m 21 rick graft take the 100th
kalaev my lions came to the site of fear and
claudia then it all starts I don’t know
I take something would you see me for cellulite
because I would have children  on and you already
understand take away pour out she will run away
from the children well than for herself and the same so
we decided that we my kudys them from or
don’t know kudinova they get out of vice
zara sprinkle 2 spend it and that’s all and
go back to the house all  three months
telepathic here I sleep here I sleep here
my child who is 16 years old I
came from the Donetsk region the city of
Selydove I didn’t intend to go at all
because I have two more adult
sons there and I didn’t want to leave them and then
when on the 11th we flew in strongly  and
literally in 20 minutes we got together with our
youngest son and came here to lions,
I know even though we have such a big gap
in years, but somehow here we are friends
[music] of the
war itself, and our friend came out of the
battery there  my
relatives lost a person and in the area there
my barrels and ended up from being afraid I’ll rush,
not more than 20 mm,
they remained with me as adult guys and they
simply didn’t let them go to any block of
posts because rogue works for me
saves people and the last three goals in
this was very shot
how then I was driving ps beloved I love
the video on the alarm was let's go to
bypassing
yes
[music] the
papers were
I know parts of the bushes bribed this all
until the canteen came back until the food
was over
[music]
and we ourselves were us once that  we won’t be
any further we are there we are already our own future
type it’s not in the kitchen we can find another
cheek everyone can wake up cotton wool on their own
a lot of volunteers come here
help us bring food
clothes
[music] of
course I don’t want this to happen anywhere else
like in  it’s our Ukraine,
then you can lay everything down, you can see the ranks there,
it’s still so kind, and all kind, you
move so
positively for everything, and then the same amount and I’m waiting
at home yesterday  a person with a higher education in
NATO and that's all
[music]
actually I really want to go home
because I'm getting half
my life here I took one child and half
of my life is mine there I don't like it I don't
want to be a migrant I want to go back there
back to where I used to live
[music]